This video is made possible by Nord VPN take control of your internet experience
today.
Go to Nord vpn.com forward slash biographics and use code biographics to get
68% off a two year plan and an extra month for free and take control of your
internet experience.
Wow.
Piracy is a treasure trove of swash buckling,
tales of lovable rogue, scallywags, and rapscallion Xoom,
merrily blue raspberries in the face of the great powers of the time.
Living a life of freedom on the high seas,
but not today's protagonist of a run of the coast.
The legendary self-governance society of Buccaneers on the Island of tortilla.
Yoga was home to many,
a legendary scoundrel who braved the waves for the love of booty dreaming
about a wealthy retirement, but not this guy. Oh no.
He was a complete and utter piece of,
he was an irredeemable criminal and a total psychopathic terrorized,
the Caribbean looting burning, killing, and torturing.
Whoever came across his path with a particular predilection for Spanish
colonists, his name was Francois Orlin,
a the most Savage pirates of the 17th century.
Before you continue watching this video, though, please do be warned.
There is some graphic Crohn's ends,
and viewer discretion is certainly advised.
[Inaudible].
Little is known about the early years of the boy who became Francoise along a
name. We do know his exact date of birth.
I knew that it was sometime between 1630 and 1635. We know that at birth,
he was called John David. Now that he was born in the small town of LaSalle,
the law in today's Vondie departments on the Atlantic coast of France.
And we know that his parents were so poor that they were forced to sell him as
an indentured servant when he was 15 years old,
the teenage on David was whisked off to the other side of the Atlantic working
first in a sugar plantation in Martinique,
and then under Spanish masters in the Island of Hispaniola.
This is where modern day Haiti and Dominican Republic are located for nine long
years. Joy injured,
a life of backbreaking work in the plantation for little or no compensation.
He was most likely mistreated and he most likely suffered physical violence.
I'm only speculating here,
but it may have been this time that something snapped inside his mind.
This is when he may have developed his latest sadistic tendencies and his
relentless hatred of the Spanish. By the late 1650s,
John David had earned his freedom as per his servitude contract.
He had the option to become a farmer in Hispaniola.
Instead he escapes that community to live among the Buccaneers.
These Buccaneers were originally hunters who roamed the wilds of Hispaniola.
They feasted on wild cattle and boar meat prepared in little hot school.
Becamse and it's their name overtime.
The name Buccaneer came to define the pirates and privateers who had found safe
Haven on the Island of [inaudible] just North of Hispaniola air in 17th
century writer,
Alexandra X square merely describes Datu UGA as common refuge of all
sorts of wickedness and the seminary as it were of pirates and
thieves.
This community of scallywags on the high seas became known as the brethren of
the coaster sort of independent rogue pirate stage with its own laws and
even a governor. When John David joined the brethren,
the governor was one more sewer Diller. Plus incidentally,
the newbie pirates served as a symbol Marriner on two or three voyages with more
experienced Buccaneers. We have a few specific details on these expeditions,
except that he developed a reputation for courage and cruelty against the enemy.
His actions impressed MSOD Plaza gave him a new battle name,
Francois [inaudible],
which simply means the man from a long delay class also gave him command of a
ship of his own as a privateer or core set serving for the French Navy. Today,
we might be using the terms pirate,
Buccaneer course air and privateer interchangeably. But once upon a time,
there was a fine distinction.
A pirate is quite simply an armed robber who works at sea attacking mainly ships
and ports.
A privateer on the other hand is a pirate who has been given authority by
government to attack and pillage ships belonging to other powers.
The government providing such authorization would receive a percentage of the
loot.
And so the newly-minted captain France while on the nae was the blessings of the
governor of Tatu governs on, in direct orders from the French crown set,
sail on his first independent voyages.
He would soon become the scourge of the main colonial power of the Caribbean,
the flail of the Spanish.
[Inaudible].
Swells first raids at sea and not documented,
but we know that they were successful in later.
Actions Lalani proved to be tactically savvy.
His favorite technique was to take large ships by surprise,
attacking them with a number of small boats.
Sometimes he would split his forces into two units.
One group on a larger vessel would engage in a gun battle with new prey while
Francois himself would lead a surprise raid from canoes,
attacking the enemy from behind he and his crew became renowned for being both
brave and cruel. During the early 1660s,
Spanish sailors have been on the receiving ends of the cruelty.
At least when it came to facing Francois, Swaran just crude.
But the Spanish Navy in the Spanish armies in the Americans were not exactly
shrinking violets and sooner or later the empire would strike back in
1667 Leilani's ship sank off the coast of campaign on the Yucatan
peninsula, modern day, Mexico,
the course Aaron Dizman disembarked and headed toward the town,
but fell into a surprise attack prepared by Spanish troops.
The ambush was well-prepared and the slaughter was almost entirely one-sided at
the end of the battle.
Most of the Buccaneers had been killed Francoise body blade among the other
cadavers smeared in a mixture of caked in blood and sand,
the Spanish soldiers Bally gave him a second look before congratulating
themselves on the victory.
But bear just for the oldest trick in the Swashbucklers book, playing dead,
realizing that all was lost.
And ed quickly covered his face with the blood of his own,
that superficial wounds and rolled in the Sans to make for a more convincing
corpse. After surviving the massacre, the Buccaneer bed,
the body of a Spanish soldier dressed in his uniform and left campaign.
He soon ran into group of slaves whom he convinced to give him a canoe without
flimsy boats.
The stubborn freshmen majored all the way back to door to gab governance.
Coloplast must've choked on his rum when he saw the man of a lawn. Once again,
allegedly back from the debt is excavated.
They have increased his pirate credentials even further as he was able to
recruit a fresh crew with his newly unkillable reputation,
with a new crew in tow Francoise set sail on his next objective,
the Spanish town of Los chaos on the Southern coast of Cuba with another ship
that his command, he had more reason than ever to target his Spanish enemies.
The incursion was spotted by fisherman who alerted the governor in the Capitol
Havana. The governor sends a 10 gun warship mans by 90 sailors and Marines.
It was more than enough to deal with the meager course air force.
He must have been surprised when only one man came back alive.
The lone survivor brought back terrible news.
The French back in air and his men had succeeded in capturing the Spanish war
ship taking nearly all the men prisoner,
Lala lay had been ordered for them all to have their feet and hands tied.
The survivors were all made to kneel in a long row.
The French course says slowly stroll along the line of captives with a Cutlass
in his right hand and a sharpening stone. And the other,
the blades of the man from a law fell onto the first Spanish neck.
Then a second, then a third without a rush.
The captain sharpens the edge of this stone and resumed as work.
When he finally shifted his Cutlass,
87 suit rolled off the bridge of the warship.
The blood thirst of the French Corsair was motivated by revenge against the
Spaniards,
but rage did not exactly obfuscate his cold calculating minds.
He spared the life of one Spanish sailor and send him back to the governor.
It was a diabolical move,
allowing that one witness tail to strike fear into the whole of Nirvana.
The survivor carried a message from Lola to the governor.
I shall never hence forward give quarter to any Spaniard whatsoever.
And I have great hopes.
I shall execute on your own pass and the very same punishments I have done upon
them. You sent against me, thus,
I have retaliated the kindness you designed to me and I companions,
but just before we get into that slaughter,
let me tell you about today's sponsor Nord VPN. If you're online,
you really should be using a VPN. And that's when Nord VPN comes in.
I know it's tempting not to bother sort of just hope for the best,
but really those stories you read about people having their data stolen,
they do happen as well. I don't want it to be easy for that to be you,
whether it's an affair,
anchor snooping for your private information or companies tracking your activity
online, protect yourself with naught, but using a VPN can be so much more.
For example,
Nord VPN lets you access any of its thousands of servers in different countries,
all around the globe. So if you've hit the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server and you'll get to content
libraries that due to licensing agreements or any available in specific
geographic locations.
I actually personally ran into that with mad men a while ago and a few other
shows. So that's pretty great. Nord VPN is also super fast.
So watching video is a breeze, no lag whatsoever.
You've ever thought using VPNs was slow. Well,
no more with nought and you can use it on all your devices, very easily,
Android Chrome windows and the next and on six different devices with one
account. Also there are no logs kept at all.
Unlike companies based in the EU or the U S nor VPN is over in Panama.
So they don't have to keep logs at all, which is great for your privacy.
So take control of your internet experience today@nordvpn.com forward slash
biographics and use the code biographics to get 68% off a two year plan
and an extra month for free and take control of your internet experience now.
And let's get back to the video.
[Inaudible].
They had upgraded his fleet with the captured Spanish warship,
but he had little loop to speak of after roaming from port to port,
he eventually attacked and pillaged a ship loaded with golden silver.
After the successful heist Francois returned to his base in tore to go where the
Gatton preparations for his most ambitious plan, yet the sack of Maracaibo,
a wealthy Spanish colonial town in modern day, Venezuela,
a plan likes this needed the rice manpower.
And so Leilani issued a recruitment call. Over 400 men joins the enterprise,
including a contingence. There was led by Mechelle the basket,
the basket pine room was already retired by now,
but he decided to return to the fray for one last heist. If you like.
He had been a very skilled infantry officer before becoming a buck near.
And so we offered to lead actions on lands.
The expedition set sail in late April 16,
67 during a stop on the Northern coast of Hispaniola.
The numbers of the Buccaneers increased to 700.
All of these fleets now fully staffed and stocked on supplies set off to America
though on July the 30th, 1667,
as the fleet was circumnavigating Hispaniola,
Alani spotted a Spanish ship just off Punto Sparta,
and what was lower than these mission statements. Well,
no quarter to the Spaniards ends, no quarter was given,
setting aside his main objective, the French privateer.
I left the bulk of his fleet behind and gave chase to the Spanish ship.
She proved to be a formidable opponent as she was armed with 16 guns.
The Buccaneers were not deterred though. And after a battle of three hours,
the Spanish surrendered Lola nade discovered that's the Congo was worth fighting
for the capture job held 120,000 pounds of cocoa, but that was just the Andre.
Bronswell also plundered,
a huge cache of coins and Juul is equivalent to 50,000 Spanish dollars of the
time. Our inflation calculator doesn't go back that far,
but you can consider it an absolutely vast amounts of money.
While Francois was raking in such copious booty,
that remainder of his fleet had not been sitting idle.
They had captured another Spanish ship carrying $12,000 as well as tons of
ammunition and weapons.
Lalani incorporated the two captured ships into his fleet,
taking the 16 gun vessel as his flagship with the holes heavy with cash and
weapons. The bucket is sailed on Tamara KIBO in August of 1667.
They landed some 18 miles away from the town preparing for a surprise attack,
but surprise it. Wasn't just the governor of Merrick.
Who'd been warned of the pirates arrival.
The governor was in charge of the life of 4,000 inhabitants and could count on
800 soldiers. Maricado had been sacked by pirates twice before in 16,
14 and 1642. That was more than enough. And the governor wouldn't let it happen.
A third time. He divided his forces into two units.
The first would deliver a frontal attack on the invaders while the other would
ambush them from the rehab. What happens next would be funny if it went,
you know, horribly violent and tragic. So yeah,
the French pirates who wanted to take America by surprise and the Spanish
stealth attack party who wanted to take the pirates by surprise.
Eventually a group of pirates led by Miguel.
The Basque discovered the Spanish ambushes and detect them by surprise the
Spanish soldiers retreated to the Fort of Maracaibo,
located some miles outside of the main town Francoise near how the baskets that
combined rate as besieged the Fort for three hours eventually capturing the
barracks, the whole plan of the governor. It was going South,
some survivors of the ambush party. He managed to reach Mariko with news.
That 2000 pirates were about to pillage the town. That's right.
They said two thousands,
not the actual 700 inevitably panic spread like a plague. Now,
considering Francois's previous tactic of allowing one survivor to escape,
one may wonder if the soldiers who spread the panic,
it's actually been set free by the crafty core SAP, whatever the truth,
the consequences, plaids in Alana's favor,
citizens of Maracaibo evacuated on mass weakening the defenses of the town,
grabbing whatever boat they found. So they quickly sell to Gibraltar. No,
not the one in Spain,
but a namesake town on the Southeast shore of Lake maricado with all the
resistance gone,
all Hernandez fleet sailed into the Harbor and then marched into America though,
without a fight, as per tradition of the Buccaneers,
all in his small army divided their Luton equal parts,
but it was a disappointing booty at this stage consisting only of food and
household items. Lala need the basket. Everyone else wanted the Spanish gold,
but no way could they find it.
They had no idea where the citizens had gone with their valuables.
The frustrated camps in sends 160 of his men into the forests around maricado
looking for prisoners.
They returned with 20 soldiers in shackles and will all in a,
had a ways to make them talk.
[Inaudible].
As unfortunate prisoners were tied up to a wooden rack and subjected to torture
all in a personally performed his favorite agony inducing methods.
One of these activities, it was known as wielding.
This first consisted of tying a rope around the head of a prisoner by twisting a
short wooden sticks that rope would tighten its grip similar to the Spanish
GoRat app.
The pressure on the skull and temples of the captives with assumption that the
eyes would eventually pop out of their sockets.
Another method was simply to cut out the tongue of the victim.
Certainly it did not help the poor guy talk,
but it sure motivated as companions to reveal any information that they might be
sitting on. The last torture worth mentioning,
consisted of slowly slicing a prisoner to pieces, full view of the others all,
and they would start with a small slice first.
Then he gradually increased the size of the carts.
Eventually hacking off entire limbs.
Eventually somebody talked and revealed that most towns folk had fled to
Gibraltar lower than eight letters, man,
to Gibraltar carrying out another surprise attack via the plans.
The Spanish in Gibraltar had been readying some defenses,
but the majority of their weapons had been left at the Fort plus they did not
expect an attack on foot from the swamp side of that position.
At the end of the fierce battle, 40 pirates lay dead and DT wounded.
The losses on the other side had been much worse,
500 dead and an unreported number of wounded to later died of sepsis,
the hunger of the Buccaneers at not been seated by this victory.
They tortured and raped the survivors,
looted all their valuables and stole their food.
Many of the remaining Spanish staff to death,
the sack of Gibraltar lost at four weeks.
And then the deranged captain Francois [inaudible] asked for more.
He knew some Spanish refugees had been hiding in the forest.
And so he sent word to them that he was going to burn the town.
As they pay him $10,000. They had two days to comply.
They finally managed to scrape the sum together on the third day. There's a lot,
all the Ned already started to set the houses on fire.
After the sack of Gibraltar was over Lola nail led the Buccaneers back to
America though, and their first stand down there not found much to steal,
but they hadn't played the rent SIM card.
Yet Francoise sent a message to the downtrodden governor asking for $30,000 to
prevent the town from being set on fire. After a tense negotiation,
the French captain settled on $20,000 and 500 pieces of cattle. Lola, Nan,
his crew of rather nasty bastards emerged from Lake Maracaibo wins into the open
sea. After two months pillaging burning, torturing and killing. They had planted
$260,000 as well as gems and luxury goods.
When they returned to talk to Lola ne was probably the most notorious pirate of
the Caribbean. Thanks to the new Leon clout and his new riches.
He was able to prepare a new expedition in 1668 with a force of some 700
men.
[Inaudible].
By now the ones indentured seven said developed delusions of grand.
He had a master false fortune, one, almost every battle.
He had forged conquered two towns.
So I don't conquer a whole country for himself.
This was the goal of his next expedition taking over the Spanish territory of
Nicaragua. The plan of Lola was to make a landing in Cape grassy as a Dios,
which is Spanish for thanks God. This Cape is the Eastern most tip of Nicaragua.
We're on the Caribbean coast and it borders on modern day Honduras,
the Corsair fleet, however,
was taken off course by a storm and push northward into the Gulf of Thundurus.
As the pirates waited for the weather and wind to improve,
they decided to bide their time by pillaging the coast and their cruelty.
The bucket is targeted smaller communities, native fishermen,
who barely had any possessions besides that cabins and canoes all in aid.
Then his men burns the natives,
humble lodgings and stole their canoes effectively destroying their livelihoods
for the sake of a very small booty.
The French captain had sowed hatred amongst the natives.
They would not forget this and they would spread the word after days of
targeting fishermen, the pirates moved to strike and more formidable opponent,
a Spanish ship armed with 20 guns, mortar Pareto to Kabyles today.
But quarters in Honduras,
the Buccaneers were able to quickly seize the ship itself.
The prey that would make any pirate proud, but it wasn't enough for LOL.
And he ordered his men to March inlands and conquer the city of San Pedro,
some 50 kilometers or 30 miles South of Coretta to Kabyles.
The Honduran jungle proved to be an Emerald health.
Both the pirates and their opponents [inaudible] was frustrated by the constant
attacks and ambushes carried out by Spanish troops hiding in the forest.
His men came across two barricaded positions built by the Spaniards offering
stiff resistance. In both occasions,
they were able to slaughter the garrisons by using rudimentary hand grenades.
Those soldiers who were not killed had a much worse feat, captivity and torture.
This was dictated by the twisted psychia Francois, the near shore,
but it also served a purpose.
The captain had realized that as men were completely encircled by the Spanish
troops, he needed to extract information on their location.
So as to reach San Pedro avoiding further casualties, Lola Neha interrogated,
the prisoners taken from the barricades,
but they would not reveal the positions of their compatriots.
The pirates went into a rage.
We don't know if it was a foaming off URI or rather a cold blood [inaudible]
psychopathic, malignant anger. What we do now,
the results from swallow and a stabbed,
one of the prisoners in the chest and launched his wound and then ripped out his
hot as the other soldiers stand on in horror,
the Savage pirates bit on the pulsating hot.
And then he shoved the organ on some poor fellow's face and forced him to eat
it. He then addressed the other prisoners. I will serve you all alike.
If you show me not another way, the remaining captives confessed,
there was a way out to the Spanish and sacraments,
but it would have been very difficult to break it. After a further battle,
the equal sander expedition managed to take San Pedro,
but it was a Pyrrhic victory.
That lines had been thinned by the constant harassment from the Spaniards.
And most of the inhabitants had fled with that possessions Walden, a perhaps,
and Pedro burns the grounds and then marched his men back to [inaudible] to
Kabyles. The bucking is of this stage. We're close to mutiny,
but Francois managed to keep up morale by promising a rich loot.
One of the prisoners told him about a large Spanish ship due to arrive in
Harbor. Within three months,
they waited patiently until she showed up arms to the teeth with 41 guns and
130 sailors while, and they applied a simple, yet effective tactic.
He targeted the Spanish ship with Kennan Vaughn from the tallest buildings,
where to the kumbaya, the artillery on board responded to the fire.
But the Spaniards did not notice the four canoes bursting with pirates
approaching from the starboard side, the course as boarded the ship on scene,
taking the Spanish by surprise. When they opened the holds of the vessels,
they were also taken by surprise.
They ones full of gold and silver as expected with Ravo full of paper and steel.
His appointment finally broke the crew, which splints it into three factions.
Two groups left on de-risk. One returned to talk to God.
The other wins around the Caribbean, seeking more ships to plunder.
Lola a and 300 men decided to remain in the Gulf of Honduras,
but it immediately appeared as though their luck had run out during one of their
first outings that ship ran aground on a sandbox for six months,
while all the Nan his men were stuck on the coast, upon the jurors,
trying to free their ship from that trap all the while they had to defend
themselves from the incessant attacks of the local tribes bends on revenge.
After the early reds of Lola NAPE week after week,
the numbers dwindled until eventually only 150 were left alive.
Francois realized that no hopes of escaping the sandbox.
So we had the ship dismantled and the ordered his men to build some bulges
within new boats.
The Buccaneers sailed South woods along the coast towards Nicaragua,
but now in a reversal of fate,
it was the Spaniards who gave no quarter chasing Lola.
Now away from the territories, the Buccaneers have no choice,
but to continue that Johnny Southwood in desperate need of food and fresh water,
all the Nan is few surviving pirates landed in the area known as the Darien
is-ness. This was one of the most hospitable areas of jungle in the world.
Even today considered to be almost impenetrable,
surrounded by a hostile environments.
The Buccaneers soon run a foul of local tribes,
most likely belonging to the Kuna people.
Some contemporary sources describe the Darian natives as inherently violent and
cannibalistic. However,
accounts of a latest Scottish expeditions of the Darwinian and 60 99 report,
how the tribes were generally welcoming and especially sympathetic to the
enemies of the Spanish.
What we can realistically assume is that the Qunar knew about the reputation of
Lala, Nan, as men for sadistic conquest,
or perhaps they were simply defending themselves against invaders. In any case,
the CUNA soon brief to be more than a match for the pirates gruesome violence.
After a series of attacks on the course,
as the natives captured the few survivors, including the man from Alon,
one of the Buccaneers survived captivity with the Qunar and was later able to
bow witness on the fate of Francois, Lola NAPE,
the locals torn in pieces,
throwing his body limb by limb into the fire and disasters into the,
as it's no trace or memory might remain of such an infamous inhuman
creature and infamous inhuman creature.
Indeed [inaudible] had gone down in history as the most bloodthirsty of the
course says of taught Douga. And probably even if the whole Caribbean,
even though the term is not often associated with pirates,
the man may have been a psychopathic killer, a man,
completely devoid of empathy who personally killed at least a hundred people.
Before we end today, I throw the gauntlet of the challenge over to you.
What pirate in history could possibly rival France while all the knee and
savagery and cruelty.
Please do let us know in the comments and as always thank you for watching.
Please do check out our fantastic sponsor. Nord VPN. Don't forget to like,
don't forget to subscribe. Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].